c'est l eurovision 92
[Musique]
en dehors de la scène c'est généralement
ici au milieu de sa forêt tropicale
humide qu'on peut trouver cali un monde
en accord parfait avec le mode de vie
qu'il a choisi un concert dans quelques
jours et malgré le challenge
il a accepté de poser sa patte convoités
sur l'album de gilles petrus musiciens
guadeloupéens
quand on s'est rencontrés la première
fois je n'avais jamais vu il est arrivé
on devait faire une tournée et puis on
est parti répéter épices ailleurs
étaient deux frères ils sont onze
séances de studio cali a sacrifié une
prestation pour se consacrer à son ami
45 ans de carrière peut-être un moyen de
combattre le trac
qu'est-ce qu'on va oublier que s'apprête
à yassa le tempo êtes fan de télé pas le
bon père bon j'ai peur de faire il faut
semaine des fois j'ai maintenant j'ai
pas peur quatorze albums dont la célèbre
pièce racines en cinq volumes
une cinquantaine de chansons une
vingtaine de tubes sont bank jose sa
voix son émotion son engagement à ses
origines ses copains musiciens de
toujours aurait eu plein de
collaboration et je pense notamment à
charly labinsky je pense à des gens
comme rémi bélanger chambre qui écrit de
très belles chansons je pense ya eu un
petit collaboration avec comme il
s'appelle roland brival il ya eu plein
de gens qui sont passés avec sauter au
sénégal le mec qui te rappellent la fête
de l'école m'a dit que tous ces gens là
j'ai vraiment des écoutes et au super
loto
et quand il est parti s'installer en
france il ya quelques années son coeur
et sa conscience battait au même rythme
pour réclamer notre âme celle de son
pays
[Musique]
c'est la recherche d'une identité et
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent on n'a
pas vraiment une identité martiniquaise
propres au niveau musical et c'est ça
que je sais après ça voilà qu'un peu que
j'ai 14 ans je fournis comme ça des
chansons connues et moins connues des
invités dont son fils tiken le choix des
chansons n'est pas encore vraiment
défini pour ce concert la contradiction
est en mode veille
la montée de bord sur le change de tous
ces morceaux là on est là pour cinq ans
la musique là on n'a pas encore fini
donc on s'est tous mis là chacun met un
peu du sien
car l'affairé manager il passait des
heureux mais vous n'avez pas joué
tellement so on a oublié ses eaux qui
savent mais il ya plus de 40 morceaux et
à six invités donc ça fait 46 morts
c'est aussi l'avis
[Musique]
la musique
moi
[Musique]
gsk pâte à dent cherbourg